it's good to wear sunscreen year round
but it is really the time of year for
sunscreen right now you may have heard
FDA warnings about chemical sunscreens
which can cause skin irritation and
other issues that's why it's best to use
a mineral sunscreen like the one by
Ginger armor it is just as effective
much safer and you'll save 15 percent
with the code Pacman the link is down
below
hey everyone welcome to the David
packman show I'm producer Pat Ford
filling in for David today as he is
traveling in California we're going to
have guest hosts for the remainder of
the week so some pretty big news on the
Donald Trump indictment front happened
over the weekend Donald Trump was
interviewed by Brett Bear on Fox News
and he couldn't get through the 20
minute or so exchange without
incriminating himself multiple times
admitting to doing the very things that
he's been accused of in this Federal
indictment Donald Trump has been doing
media interviews he's been doing these
rallies wherein he talks about the
criminal charges and basically admits to
the fact that he had these classified
documents in his possession and
obstructed Justice thereafter this is of
course a terrible idea for any criminal
defendant any Council defense lawyers
would advise you not to speak about the
case but because Donald Trump is running
for president and he needs to at all
times appear like he's a fighter her he
believes he's smarter than everyone else
he is deciding to just do it anyway to
talk about the case and what he's been
doing really is giving himself more and
more rope to hang himself with and
that's because generally speaking the
prosecution can use such statements that
you make in the media
to establish your guilt or to try to
undermine your defense arguments and
legally it can get more complicated of
course because you get into a
conversation about what is and what
isn't admissible in court what does and
what doesn't qualify is hearsay but
there's a strong case that these media
interviews like the one we're about to
look at by Trump will end up being used
as exhibits in his upcoming trial so the
bottom line is this is why you stay
silent I think it was Ron philipkowski
on Twitter who said that if the 500 best
lawyers in the entire world told Donald
Trump to stay silent on this matter he
would disregard them thinking that he
was smarter than all of them and then
Maga would use that as justification to
vote for him because they would think
that that's some sort of qualification
for being president even though that
would actually make him the worst
possible choice to be president zeroing
in on the most damaging things that
Donald Trump said during this interview
Trump admits to taking the documents
down to Mar-A-Lago with him and that he
had the these boxes of documents in his
possession that they were interspersed
with his personal possessions and this
is all going to the charge of willful
retention of National Defense
information he's admitting to the whole
thing here let's take a look at the clip
why did you have this very sensitive
National Security defense documents like
the war plans for a strike on Iran so
like every other president I take things
out and in my case I took it out pretty
much in a hurry but people packed it up
and we we left and I had clothing in
there I had all sorts of personal items
and there much much stuff I have every
right to have those boxes this is purely
a presidential records act this is not a
criminal thing in fact the New York
Times have all had a story just the
other day that the only way Nara could
ever get this stuff this back would be
please please please could we have it
back please because they had
and then they said they went to doj to
subpoena you to get which they've never
done before right and you know why not
just hand them over them because I had
boxes I want to go through the boxes and
get all my personal things out I don't
want to hand that over to Nara yet and I
was very busy as you've sort of seen
yeah but according to your diamonds you
then tell this Aid to move to other
locations after telling your lawyers to
say you'd fully complied with the
subpoena when you hadn't but before I
send boxes over I have to take all of my
things out these boxes were interspersed
with all sorts of things uh golf shirts
clothing pants shoes there were many
things I would say much much more not
that I know of but not that I know of so
it's hard not to laugh when Trump is
talking about his golf shirts and his
shoes that he had to take out before
sending the boxes back from Nara but I
think that the key takeaway from the
entire statement here is that he does
admit to taking the documents he admits
that he was in contact with Nera about
sending them back and his defense was
essentially that he was too busy he
didn't have time to get around to it
even though he was subpoenaed in this
case and once you receive a subpoena
you're supposed to realize oh this is
actually serious if the fact that you
were in contact with authorities before
the subpoena wasn't enough of a message
to take this thing seriously The
subpoena should have done it for you but
he decided to continue to ignore it and
to have his lawyers lie to the
authorities about what exactly he had in
his possession remember that key in this
case is the charge of willful retention
of National Defense information that's
what 31 of the 37 counts hinge on and
he's saying yeah I did it it wouldn't
matter if his golf shirts were also in
there or if they weren't in there or if
he had time to get around to it or if he
didn't have time to get around to it
he seems to be guilty of these crimes
now let's move on to the audio tape this
is something that prosecutors have in
their possession tape of Donald Trump
while he's showing a guest of his who
presumably doesn't have a security
clearance classified material and he
admits that he could have Declassified
it while he was president but he didn't
and now he doesn't have the authority to
do so anymore so therefore it is still
classified Trump's arguments surrounding
his right to have these documents depend
on him saying that he could have
Declassified whatever he wanted to as
president telepathically even right well
this isn't true because we've heard from
excerpts about this there's this process
that you have to go through to
declassify information particularly when
it comes to things like nuclear secrets
and other top level confidential
information that the government has but
even if it was true this tape that
prosecutors have completely undermines
the argument right because we know for
sure that Donald Trump didn't even
attempt to declassify the documents by
declaration telepathically or otherwise
and now he can't because he's no longer
president he admits to this so this is
among the strongest pieces of evidence
that the prosecution has it's really
what could end up doing him in and Trump
is doing himself no favors by talking
about this very specific piece of uh
information of evidence that the
prosecution has and he provides just the
absolute worst defense that anyone could
possibly come up with falling right into
the Trap of talking about it because
Brett Baer happened to bring it up
according to the indictment you were
here at Bedminster on July 21st 2021
after you're no longer president and you
were recorded saying that you had a
document detailing a planned attack on
another country that was prepared by the
U.S military for you when you were
president the Iran attack plan you
remember that
I had lots of paper I had copies of
newspaper articles I had copies of
magazines this is specifically a quote
you're quoted on the recording saying
the document was secret adding that you
could have Declassified it while you
were president but quote now I can't you
know this is still secret highly
confidential and the indictment sets the
recording and the testimony from people
in the room saying you showed it to
people there that day so you say on this
is just the opposite that you can't
declassify so why have it what I said
when I said that I couldn't be
classified now this because I wasn't
president I I never made any bones about
that when I'm not president I can't eat
less if I that's what you said you
didn't I said no no I said I couldn't
have that because of my document Brad
there was no document that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things and
it may have been held up or may not but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se there was nothing to
declassify these were newspaper stories
magazine stories and articles I'm just
saying what the indictment said so
number one Donald Trump does not deny
that the recording exists or that the
conversation happened which is
interesting because I've been hearing in
many right-wing circles on right-wing
programs that the audio tape was clearly
artificial intelligence they can't come
up with any sort of reasonable excuse
for why Trump would be saying this so
they're saying okay it must have been a
deep fake you can do a lot with AI these
days but Donald Trump himself is not
using that excuse right he's not even
disputing the fact that the conversation
took place he's disputing what the
conversation was about but he's not
disputing that it happened or that that
was him in that conversation so we can
put to bed now this weak excuse that the
right has come up with that that must
have been a i and not actually Trump on
the recording furthermore Trump says
that these weren't documents that he was
showing his guests but instead they were
newspaper clippings and articles and I
don't know how Brett Baer didn't pick up
on this in real time but this is a
totally nonsensical statement right how
could newspaper clippings and articles
be considered government classified
documents by their very definition
newspaper clippings and articles are
meant for public consumption whereas
government secrets are kept as these
private documents and Donald Trump says
on the tape it's classified I'm not
supposed to be showing you this so
Donald Trump really just digging himself
his own grave and he's had plenty of
time to come up with a proper defense
when it comes to the audio tape
specifically that's the most damaging
piece of evidence seemingly against him
and this is all he can do just kind of
stumble around and again all this stuff
can be used against him in court
presumably so obviously this is a unique
case I don't think he's going to take a
plea deal or anything like this because
he has to show that he's a true fighter
but with all this stuff and with all the
damaging things that he said to the
media all the times that he's implicated
himself that would be the best course of
action for him he's not going to go
through with that most likely he's going
to go to trial and I'm sure he's banking
on the fact that he has this right-wing
judge that he appointed presiding over
the case and the possibility that
because the trial is being held in South
Florida there'll be enough trumpists on
the jury to get him the not guilty
verdict or maybe give him a hung jury I
think that's what he's trying to do here
and I understand how he feels as if he
has to talk about the case because of
the politics of it because he's running
for president again and he has to look
like a fighter but it's just not good
strategically from a criminal
prosecution standpoint if you're trying
to stay out of prison and one more clip
I wanted to show you from this Brett
Bear interview
Brett Bear talked about how Trump has to
bring new voters into his camp in order
to defeat Biden in 2024 and so Brett
Baier asked the question if you're
speaking one-on-one to an independent
voter how are you going to convince them
to vote for you in 2024 if they didn't
vote for you in 2020 and without missing
a step Donald Trump goes right into
conspiracy theories about the 2020
election the question wasn't even about
the 2020 election specifically and
whether Trump won or lost but Trump has
to jump right in and say that he
actually won the election even though
this was not being disputed at the time
Brett Baer so let's take a look at this
and so to the female independent voter
in the suburbs who struggled with family
financing because of inflation she's now
against Biden disapproves of Biden but
wasn't with you in 2020 and so far is a
hard no for you in 2024 but what do you
say what do you say to that female
independent Suburban voter who feels
that way to win her back first of all I
won in 2020 by a lot okay let's get that
straight I won in 2020. you know and if
you look at all of the tapes if you look
at everything that you want to look at
you take a look at truth to vote where
they have people stuffing the ballot
boxes on tapes or Mr President okay wait
a minute let's go to recent FBI Twitter
let's go to recent the 51 agents all
corrupt stuff bro understand about the
water buttons
but that's cheating on them you lost the
2020 election uh Brad you take a look at
all of the stuff ballots you take a look
at all of the things including things
like the 51 intelligence agents there
were recounts in all of the Swing states
there was not significant ones we're
trying to get recounts real recounts
numbers widespread corruption there was
not a sense of that there were lawsuits
more than 50 of them by your lawyers
some in front of judges judges that you
appointed look at Wisconsin I came out
with Wisconsin
Wisconsin is practically admitted it was
rigged other states are doing the same
right now and it's continuing
every potential case of voter fraud in
six Battleground States and they found
fewer than 475 cases you know why
because they didn't look at the right
thing okay are you going they were
counting they were counting about
balance not the authenticity of the
ballot the ballots were fake ballots you
had this was a very rigorous are you
going to go this is how you're going to
tell that independent Suburban woman
voter vote off to winning an election
and I think we're winning very well uh I
got a poll just recently I have it here
on no no I know okay so it's not even
worth going through Donald Trump's
claims there one by one we've done that
ad nauseum over the years and Brett
Baird does a decent job at fact checking
him in real time but I thought that bear
especially did well at the end there by
emphasizing the fact that his question
was about how do you win over an
undecided female independent voter who
didn't vote for you in 2020 and your
response has been to complain about
voter fraud even though the public is
tired of hearing about this issue it's
not a winning issue for you it's not a
voting issue for people Independence
especially it's not policy you're not
being convincing when you talk about
this it's uninspiring and then Trump
tries to course correct but instead of
doing it in the standard way of talking
about you know the normal policy issues
the economy the Border guns even culture
War stuff if you want to get into it
instead he diverts into talking about
how he's winning in all the polls so
people should vote for him because he's
winning like how does this add up how
does this follow logically so Trump's
appeal to the independent voter who
didn't vote for him in 2020 is number
one the election was rigged in 2020 and
it was unfairly stolen for me therefore
I deserve another term
and number two I'm winning in the polls
already so you should vote for me
because I'm winning so I gotta say this
guy doesn't look like his normal self he
seems a little bit rattled I'm sure he's
worried about the possibility of serving
time in prison I'm sure he's worried
about the possibility of not winning an
election again because it devastated him
so much the last time that happened
maybe I'm looking too much into the body
language maybe I'm looking too much into
the facial expressions but to me this
seems like a very concerned man who
doesn't have the Poise and the
confidence that he normally does that's
Donald Trump for you right now not
feeling his best I gotta say and not
getting the best end end of this
exchange with Brett Bear all right we're
going to go to a break now we'll be back
with much more of the David packman show
on the other side it is Springtime it's
getting warm we are all spending more
time outside many sunscreens contain
elements that the FDA has warned about
oxybenzone a Eva Ben Zone homo sailate
and others these are absorbed into your
bloodstream they can irritate sensitive
skin they can be hormone disruptors I
just stay away from them and I use
mineral sunscreens I do the same when I
put sunscreen on my baby daughter and
our sponsor Ginger armor makes the
world's thinnest 100 mineral sunscreen
it works for all skin types not just
gingers as the name might suggest it
rubs in clear on all skin tones feels
like nothing is on with SPF 50 plus
protection Ginger armor also acts as a
plant-based moisturizer with 21 simple
gentle ingredients from plants and
minerals it's good for you it's good for
the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm producer Pat Ford filling in for
David today while he's away some pretty
big news broke yesterday which is that
Hunter Biden the son of President Joe
Biden has reached a tentative agreement
with Federal prosecutors to plead guilty
to two minor tax charges and to admit to
the facts of a gun charge the plea deal
will likely keep Hunter Biden out of
jail and it's subject to approval by a
federal judge which is likely going to
happen the proposed deal includes
pleading guilty to two misdemeanor tax
charges for failures to pay taxes in
2017 and 2018 with a combined liability
of approximately 1.2 million dollars
prosecutors are going to recommend
probation for the tax charges and then
the gun charge is going to be handled as
a diversion case where Hunter will be
able to technically not have to plead
guilty to the crime and he'll be able to
do so if he successfully meets the
measures outlined in the diversion
program the gun charge will ultimately
likely be removed from his record so
Hunter Biden's gun charge stems from a
false statement that he made on
paperwork while he was purchasing a gun
he denied drug use or having a drug
problem when in fact that wasn't true
lying on gun purchase forms is only a
small percentage of firearm related
prosecutions and typically it's tacked
on as a secondary offense and that seems
to be what happened here Hunter Biden's
lawyer stated that he takes
responsibility for the tax mistakes made
during a period of turmoil and addiction
in his life the full statement from his
lawyer Chris Clark was quote Hunter will
take responsibility for two instances of
failure to file tax payments when due
a firearm charge which will be subject
to a pre-trial diversion agreement and
will not be the subject of the plea
agreement will also be filed by the
government I know Hunter believes it is
important to take responsibility for
these mistakes he made during a period
of turmoil and addiction in his life he
looks forward to continuing his recovery
and moving forward the White House for
its part has expressed support for
Hunter Biden stating that the president
and the first lady love their son and
support his efforts to rebuild his life
so I hear all this information and I
think that all right it looks like
justice has been served Hunter Biden
clearly did some stuff wrong and he
appears to have committed some crimes
here he didn't pay taxes that he owed to
the federal government that effectively
is stealing from the rest of us and so
he should have to pay his fair share
just like anybody else he did lie while
going through the process of obtaining a
weapon and you can't say that you're not
using drugs when going through that
process when you actually are at the
time you may disagree about whether that
should be illegal or not but the law
says that it is currently and so sure he
should be held accountable for it
and I think that the correct agreement
was ultimately reached here he takes the
plea deal he gets a slap on the wrist
with the probation he doesn't have to go
to jail or anything like that it doesn't
seem to me like these amount to jail
worthy crimes anyway we can end it now
right this is really not all that hard
and I don't look at this case and think
oh I have to defend Hunter Biden at all
costs I really don't care about Hunter
Biden right I apply the same standard
when it comes to anyone facing criminal
charges right whether it's Trump whether
it's Biden Hillary whoever if there's
something to investigate you should
investigate if there's something to
charge then you should charge if it can
be proven in court then go ahead and
prove it and ultimately if a sentence is
warranted whether that be sending
someone to prison or otherwise then
sentence them appropriately but with the
Maga folks they pretend as though Hunter
Biden this whole time has been like Al
Capone or Charles Manson when in reality
these are pretty minor charges and at
the same time they defends Donald Trump
no matter what
when he's accused of keeping the
nation's top secrets in his bathroom at
Mar-A-Lago that anyone can just stumble
upon if they knew their way around the
resort and he of course refused to give
the documents back after months and
months of the National Archives asking
and that's just one of the multiple
criminal investigations now criminal
prosecutions that Donald Trump is
dealing with also relevant to this is
the fact that Donald Trump was actually
president and wants to be president
again whereas Hunter Biden I hate to
break it to you but he's actually not
the president he just so happens to be
related to the current president he is
the son of the president but that
doesn't mean that he is the president he
doesn't even work in his father's
Administration we've of course discussed
this ad nauseum but I suppose the
question now is how is the Republican
party going to react to the news of
Hunter Biden taking this plea deal
because they can do a couple of things
right they can either act triumphant and
say look he's technically pleaded guilty
so it proves that the Biden crime family
narrative we've been pushing this entire
time is true it shows how Joe Biden by
extension is unfit to be president or
something like that
or on the other hand they could take the
approach of saying look how the
prosecutors in this case treated Hunter
Biden with kid gloves and they let him
go free not sending him to jail even
though this is a very standard plea deal
and Trump has had plenty of
opportunities to cooperate with
investigators and it will probably be
offered plea deals as well I just don't
think he's going to take them so in
reality the right-wing media is probably
going to do a mix of both when talking
about this hunter story depending on
whatever serves them best at the time
but I do believe ultimately this is the
best outcome for this case Bill Barr
Donald Trump's former Attorney General
continues to attack his former boss you
may remember that last week Bill Barr
commented on the indictment having to do
with the alleged mishandling of
classified documents when he went on Fox
News Sunday and said that if even half
of the indictment is true then Trump is
toast he also rebuked Trump's legal
teams claims that the matter should fall
under the presidential records act
rather than the Espionage Act in full
bill R said that if even half of it is
true then he is toast I mean it's a
pretty it's a very detailed indictment
and it's very very damning and these
were big statements of course because of
who they were coming from the top
prosecutor in the Trump Administration
for a time Bill Barr Trump then
responded to Bill Barr's statements by
calling him a gutless pig well fast
forward to this weekend this past
weekend when Bill Barr was on Face the
Nation on CBS and Barr is actually
stepping up the criticism he's not
backing down he's now calling Trump a
consummate narcissist who will put his
own interests his own ego above
everything else he also called Trump a
Defiance nine-year-old kid and a
fundamentally flawed person who engages
in Reckless conduct so there's a couple
of Clips I want to play for you from
this interview the first has to do with
the legal arguments Barr decimates the
idea that Trump had the right to take
the records under the presidential
records act and it's simply unilaterally
disclassify them without going through a
process telepathically or otherwise Bill
Barr says that he had absolutely no
right to do that and he had no right to
possess the documents the legal Theory
by which he gets to take battle plans
and sensitive National Security
information as his personal papers is
absurd it's just as wacky as the legal
Doctrine they came up with for you know
having the vice president unilaterally
determine who won the election
the whole purpose of the statute the
presidential records Act is was to stop
presidents from taking official
documents out of the White House it was
passed after Watergate that's the whole
purpose of it and therefore it
restricted what a president can take it
says it's purely private that had
nothing to do with uh the uh
deliberations of government policy
obviously these documents are not purely
private it's it's obvious and they're
not even now arguing that it's purely
private what they're saying is the
president just has sweeping discretion
to say they are even though they
squarely don't fall within the
definition it's an absurd argument so
Barr says it the presidential records
Act was meant to restrict the rights of
presidents not to grant them immunity or
give them more power and it's not even
relevant to this case because this has
to do with national Secrets not just
Trump's daily diary or anything
innocuous so it's not something that
would fall under the presidential
records act This falls under the
Espionage Act and then we get into the
fun part this is when Bill Barr talks
about the possibility of trump becoming
the nominee and becoming president again
and the impact that that would have on
the country let's take a look at this
Trump has you know has many good
qualities and he accomplished some good
things but the fact of the matter is he
is a consummate narcissist and he
constantly engages in Reckless conduct
that that puts uh his political
followers at risk and and the
conservative and Republican agenda at
risk would he put the country at risk if
he was in the white house again he will
always put his own interests and
gratifying his own ego ahead of
everything else including the country's
interest there's no question about it
this is a perfect example of that he's
like you know he's like a nine-year-old
defiant nine-year-old kid who's always
pushing the glass toward the edge of the
table defying his parents to stop him
from doing it it's a means of
self-assertion and exerting his
dominance over other people and he's a
very Petty individual who will always
put his interests ahead of the countries
his personal gratification of his you
know of his ego but our country our
country can't you know can't be a
therapy session for you know a troubled
man like this blistering words there
from Bill Barr but let's put it all into
perspective Barr was also critical of
Donald Trump when it came to January 6th
and the allegations of voter fraud in
the 2020 election he famously would not
go along with the plan and to try to
overturn the election results and he
resigned a few weeks before the end of
the Trump Administration but then he was
asked if he'd vote for Trump over a
Democrat and he actually said yes that
the threat of Donald Trump is not
greater than the threat of a progressive
being put into power so Barr believes
that Trump is like a nine-year-old child
he believes that he's a consummate
narcissist he believes that he's someone
who puts his own interests in front of
the country someone who is wrong on the
law wrong on the morals someone who is
presumably guilty of crimes and yet Barr
thinks that that guy is a better vote
than boring old Joe Biden or someone
else who is in the Democratic party
because of I don't know Socialism or
inflation or something like that so I
believe it's useful to bring up Bill
Barr's statements when arguing these
issues specifically with Trump
supporters because if you're in a
discussion about classified documents
and you can effectively bring up someone
who works in the Trump Administration to
rebuke Trump's own talking points I
think that that can actually maybe get
you somewhere right because this is
someone who actually was an ally of
trump who is just not willing to stand
with him when it comes to this very
issue but that doesn't mean that we're
re rehabilitating William Barr here it
doesn't mean that uh we can point to him
as someone who is morally upstanding and
right about other things it's really
just like the same analysis that we have
when it comes to George W bush because
bush from time to time will criticize
Donald Trump and we acknowledge that
bush is capable of making coherent
points when it comes to the damage that
Donald Trump is doing to the country
while not overlooking the damage that
George W bush did to the country when it
comes to the needless Wars when it comes
to the war criminality
and everything else that he did during
his eight years so that's Bill Barr for
you absolutely he's no hero or anything
like that but he is someone that maybe
you can bring up when it comes to this
conversation about mishandling of
classified documents the fact that even
Trump's own former AG is not standing by
him when it comes to this issue let's go
to a break and we'll be back with much
more of the David packman show right
after this
with Donald Trump getting federally
indicted there have been a number of
people coming out of the woodwork to
make the case that the best thing for
the country right now would be for
President Joe Biden to step in and
pardon Donald Trump for the crimes that
he's accused of the arguments tend to
center around this idea of healing the
country or assuring people that the
Department of Justice and law
enforcement in this country apply the
law equally and they're not operating in
any sort of political fashion
there have been a number of people in
media making this case and I came across
this one op-ed in the hill I wanted to
rebut having to do with this topic it's
called the nine reasons Biden should
pardon Trump it's written by chip Muir
so I thought it would be good to go
through these arguments one by one to go
through all of Chip's nine points and
see if any of these arguments are
convincing so reason number one that
chip provides is that first historical
precedence in the aftermath of Watergate
suggests that a pardon would be the best
outcome for the nation on August 9 1974
President Nixon resigns the presidency
in the wake of Watergate one on
September 8th President Gerald Ford
pardoned him the gesture curtailed the
acrimony of over continued Watergate
Fallout and started the process of
moving forward though Nixon felt he was
innocence of criminal conducts and
should not have to accept a pardon the
pardon ended his legal Jeopardy and
allowed him to acknowledge he should
have handled the situation better in
either case a humbling yet gracious
Lifeline allowed America to move forward
well just because it happened once
before that one president pardoned
another that doesn't mean that it has to
happen again and it certainly doesn't
mean that it was the right move it
doesn't mean that it was right for a
Ford to do so and also you have to
remember that Ford and Nixon were in the
same party Ford was of course Nixon's VP
for a time so there was a political
reason to Pardon as well to protect the
interests of the Republican party at the
time now you can make the case that the
pardon did allow the country to heal
from Watergate and move forward but I
would argue that we would also have had
that healing had Nixon been charged and
gone through the criminal process
whether he was found guilty or not then
once it was all said and done even
though it would have taken a little bit
longer sure then we could realize that
okay justice has been served in this
case Nixon was treated just like any
other criminal defendant would be and
the jury came up with their decision the
judge carried out the sentence and Bam
justice has been served now we can move
on as a country from this Watergate
scandal that ultimately still would have
happened it may have taken a little bit
longer but that would have been a
totally fine course of action in my mind
also we have to remember that Gerald
Ford didn't win a term of his own he
lost to Jimmy Carter in the 1976
Presidential election suggesting that
maybe the American people wanted to see
Nixon prosecuted instead of getting this
pardon
now we continue uh second it is
historically unprecedented for an
American president to prosecute his
likely opponent the U.S has had six
presidential election rematches
including the John Quincy Adams Andrew
Jackson rematch of an alleged stolen
election regardless of personal belief
over legitimate legitimacy of the
indictment the action itself is
unprecedented Republicans are sure to
and should use this indictment against
Biden to show a weak and continuously
weakening presidents trying to use his
power to slant an election a pardon
takes away this talking point as Biden
would be using his official part in
power to avoid handicapping his likely
opposition well I gotta say it's also
unprecedented to have a president like
Trump who didn't care one iota about the
rule of law in this country who time and
time again showed his depravity and his
corruption Biden also for his part is
staying out of this and he's saying that
uh he's not going to talk about the case
it's the doj after all that is
Prosecuting him there's no evidence that
Biden himself has anything to do with
the charging decision and if Biden does
pardon Trump then Republicans ultimately
are not going to be gracious and kind
they're just going to keep attacking him
they're going to talk about the other
issues like inflation and the culture
War and the border and guns and they'll
continue to criticize Biden it's if
anything going to make Biden look like a
pushover and like he's weak if he
decides to do this and pardon Donald
Trump we continue third Biden would
appear magnanimous as a candidate the
Biden Camp tried to paint him as looking
presidential and restoring Norms reality
has painted a different picture from his
underwater approval ratings net minus 14
weakness among independent voters and
video clips that routinely show
confusion Biden has failed to live up to
the image his campaign wanted to project
but a pardon would be a shockingly
magnanimous gesture Shoring up any such
image problem look if voters are trying
to find the most magnanimous candidates
they're already going to go with Joe
Biden because they know who by is he's
an empathetic person he cares about the
average working class person whereas
Trump is seen as vindictive and this
egomaniac type if it's a battle about
who is the most magnanimous obviously
Joe Biden is going to win that every day
of the week he doesn't have to Pardon
Donald Trump to get a reputation of
being magnanimous for the better person
when it comes to personal values fourth
Biden has his own classified documents
problem he's had documents in his
University of Pennsylvania office and
classified documents in his garage near
his Corvette offering a pardon minimizes
the accusations of double standards at
play this is a false equivalence there
is a world of difference when it comes
to the types of records that both
Presidents had in their possession the
amount of documents and how serious they
were the level of classification that
they had and more importantly Joe Biden
cooperated his lawyers turned over the
documents and questions immediately no
questions asked whereas Donald Trump
lied to the authorities repeatedly and
refused to hand them back even when
faced with a subpoena fifth Americans
are rightfully concerned about the
overreach of federal agencies and
political matters expect president Trump
to vigorously defend himself with
accusations of political motivations at
trial while it may or may not help a
trial it will work as a political tactic
with the electorate by this logic Barack
Obama should have pardoned Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump should have
pardoned Democrats like Hunter Biden who
were embroiled and Scandal just pardon
anyone that's being investigated is
apparently the point that's being made
here so it doesn't look like federal
agencies are interfering too much in our
politics what would actually happen if
this was the case was would be that we
would create this sentiment where our
Elites are completely Above the Law we
already have that sentiment here in this
country you would exacerbate that and
you would make it clear that there's a
two-tiered system of justice in this
country one for the elites who are
getting pardons left and right and one
for regular folks who have to go through
the criminal process and maybe found
convicted and sent to jail without the
possibility of getting part of
themselves because they're nobodies
after all sixth in the art of the deal
Trump discussed the Anti-Trust suit his
usfl brought against the NFL and
specifically mentioned how important it
was that the NFL on a daily basis gave
interviews to win in the court of public
opinion president Trump will use every
day in the run-up to trial and at trial
to rail against the corruption of Biden
and his doj and FBI by offering a pardon
and not providing Trump with the
spotlight of a trial President Biden
would take away Trump's ability to
demonstrate how unfairly without
precedent he has been treated by
offering a pardon President Biden would
take away Trump's most significant
campaign opportunity his trial I gotta
tell you Trump is going to be able to
capture the media's attention no matter
what no matter if this trial is taking
place or not he's going to be able to
use all of this stuff to his political
Advantage when it comes to his base at
least no matter what even if this case
is dropped because you gotta remember
he's also going to have other trials to
concern himself with including trials
that are outside the purview of
President Joe Biden like the one out of
York for example and the one out of
Georgia that's likely going to come in
the next few weeks so even if Biden was
to do this for the sake of not making
the trial a focal point in the election
well Trump could just talk about the
other trials that he's dealing with and
you're not going to accomplish getting
this out of the campaign Focus just by
pardoning Donald Trump is the point
seventh the converse of President Biden
looking magnanimous and offering the
pardon is that Trump would potentially
look weak innocent men do not need
pardons the pardon is a lifeline and so
on
and it's the same concern that Nixon
expressed during his month of purgatory
after resigning the pardon would make
him look guilty when he wanted public
exoneration accepting a pardon would be
the logical and rational decision for
Trump but Democrats can spin it to say
that Trump needed Biden's generous
pardon to avoid a certain conviction and
imprisonment now this one of course is
just silly because we know that if Biden
pardons Trump then Trump would just turn
around and make the argument that look
the Biden administration had this flimsy
case against me they knew that I was
going to beat the charges so strongly in
court that they had no choice but to
Pardon Me and his supporters will eat
that up they're not going to think that
Trump is somehow weak and presumably
guilty because he accepted a pardon
that's just not how Trump and his
supporters operate also chip writes
about how innocent men don't need
pardons well innocent men also aren't
convicted of crimes at least not
typically of course there are some cases
where that happens but generally
speaking innocent men are convicted of
crimes so if you want to paint Trump as
a criminal and that's I suppose the
strategy for going forward politically
just let the process play out because it
looks like this is a rock solid case
against him and Trump is likely going to
end up convicted here eighth Trump might
moot the issue by declining the pardon
Trump is a fighter he will want to
vindicate himself in both the court of
law and the court of public opinion he
might see a pardon as denying him that
opportunity making it very difficult for
him to accept the pardon by offering the
pardon knowing full well that it might
not be accepted by Trump Biden puts
Trump in the difficult position of
either losing his chance at public
Vindication due to the generosity of his
opponent or risking a trial and
conviction after a way out had been
offered in this sense offering a pardon
is a no risk proposition for Biden we're
really grasping at straws at this point
Trump is potentially going to spend the
rest of his life in prison over these
charges there's a real possibility of
that at the very least even if you think
it's unlikely because he's a former
president these are serious charges and
there's going to likely be some
consequences for them he's terrified of
that he wouldn't reject the pardon
because he knows that there's a serious
possibility of him ending up in jail
rejecting the pardon would make no sense
politically because he could just like I
said use this to his advantage and say
that
it was he was pardoned because of the
flimsy case against him he would accept
it in a second right because that would
just be one thing he doesn't have to
worry about and he wouldn't think that
it would be any sort of liability for
himself in the 2024 election he would
see it as Democrats admitting to the
fact that there was a Witch Hunt against
him ninth and last the progressive wing
of the democratic party has spent years
trying to destroy Trump and they have
been beaten each time the progressive
Wing would be furious if Trump escapes
their clutches because Trump was
pardoned but Biden's polling with
Independence is deeply underwater and
these swing voters are also polling at a
net minus 55 points on the question of
whether the nation is on the right or
the wrong track offering a pardon
knowing how deeply unpopular the move
would be with progressives would
demonstrate that Biden is not beholden
to that wing of his party alternatively
failing to offer a pardon would be
further proof that he is beholden to the
most extreme voices in the Democratic
party and bog him down even further with
Independence well I certainly disagree
with the premise when it comes to this
one because progressives have had their
wins against Donald Trump over the years
from the two impeachments to defeating
him at The Ballot Box in 2020 to taking
the house in 2018 in the senate in 2020
and then fighting off the Red Wave in
2022 also I'm not sure the progressives
are more in favor of Prosecuting Trump
than generic Democrats are I'd like to
see the polling on that one but the most
important thing from this ninth Point
here is that you're maybe ignoring the
other side of the equation you can say
that okay it's possible that Biden will
pick up some independence from pardoning
Trump but he couldn't he also lose some
of those progressives you're talking
about if he decides to do this couldn't
some progressives decide to vote third
party or vote for a challenger to Biden
in the primary or stay home altogether
you have to calculate that also into
your equation so overall those are the
nine arguments I don't think any of them
make sense or are all that convincing if
you want to show that no person is above
the law no matter how rich or powerful
they may be then you have to prosecute
when you have reasonable suspicion that
crimes were committed otherwise you are
giving Trump and the people who come
after him the green light to do whatever
they want because they think that
they'll get away with it and even if
they don't entirely get away with it
then they'll get a pardon and
effectively ultimately get away with it
so I wonder if Trump was accused of more
serious violent crimes whether people
like chipmur would be making these exact
same points because they all would apply
right and maybe it's taking it to an
absurd level to say that everyone would
be calling for Biden to Pardon Trump if
Trump had committed a crime like murder
or something like that but it shouldn't
be even viewed through that lens it
should just be viewed as their crimes on
the books and if anyone no matter who
you are commits them is accused of
committing them you're going to be
taking through the criminal process and
treated just like anybody else all right
we're going to go to a break now but
we'll be back with the final segment of
the David packman show after these
commercial messages thank you
a couple of the Republican presidential
candidates are now taking issue with the
Loyalty pledge that they have to take in
order to appear on the debate stage this
summer The Pledge is that if you choose
to run in the Republican primary and you
don't win you are going to promise to
support the eventual nominee of the
party of course there's nothing legally
binding when it comes to this it's just
a rule that the RNC came up with to
Signal Party Loyalty that they're going
to join together once all is said and
done to defeat Joe Biden well the Donald
Trump situation really throws a wrench
into this plan as it did back in 2016.
you may remember that in 2015-16 the
Republicans on the debate stage were all
asked to raise their hand if they plan
to support the eventual Republican
nominee and Trump was the only one who
wouldn't commit to it basically saying
it's me or I'm taking the party down
with me now in 2023 2024 Trump is making
things complicated once again because
there is a serious chance that by the
time people are casting their votes in
the primary uh he and by the time the
general election comes around and he's
campaigning against Joe Biden that he's
a convicted felon or potentially close
to becoming a convicted felon and at
least two candidates now in the
Republican field Chris Christie and ASA
Hutchinson are expressing doubt about
about whether they could bring
themselves to vote for a convicted felon
ASA Hutchinson told Politico quote I'm
not going to vote for him if he's a
convicted felon he also went on to say
I'm not going to vote for him if he's
convicted of Espionage and I'm not going
to vote for him if he's convicted of
other serious crimes and I'm not going
to support him they need to put a little
rationality to what is said in that oath
or that pledge basically trying to
negotiate with the terms of the Pledge
are in order for him to be willing to
sign on to it this led to a meeting
between the Hutchinson campaign against
the RNC and the RNC made clear that they
were not going to make any adjustments
to their pledge and it's going to stand
as is so ASA Hutchinson who is currently
not polling very well he's lucky lucky
to show up at one percent of the polling
apparently not having the pull on the
RNC that he would have hoped for but he
is not alone in calling for the pledge
to be amended for the language to be
changed Chris Christie the former New
Jersey governor is also expressing
doubts about signing the pledge he said
quote I think the pledge is just a
useless idea Jake and by the way in all
my life we never had to have Republican
primary candidates take a pledge you
know we were Republicans and the idea is
you'd support the Republican whether you
won or whether you lost you didn't have
to ask somebody to sign something so I
understand how Hutchinson and Christy
are trying to get attention with
statements like this I understand how
this is giving them the media access
that they need right now to draw
attention to their campaigns but this
doesn't seem to be a winning strategy to
me in fact this seems to be like an
unforced error because you're now giving
the RNC a reason to disqualify you from
the debates I mean ASA himself is saying
that he may not sign it all together
Chris Christie is saying that he may not
sign it in Earnest why would you do that
right just sign the pledge and don't
take it seriously and if it comes down
to it come up with some excuse for why
you ultimately were unable to honor the
pledge you can just say something like
oh the uh crimes that Trump has been
accused of or convicted of they're much
more serious than you initially realized
when you signed the pledge and that's
why you can no longer honor it just come
up with something like that it's
basically what Trump does right it's the
Trump approach of saying and doing
anything that helps you in the short
term and then later if you have to
change your mind just blame everyone and
everything else for why you had to come
around on the idea so this situation
actually reminds me of the microvelt
campaign in 2019-2020 you may remember
him he was running for president in the
Democratic primary despite being around
90 years old and he did so not because
he viewed himself as a serious candidate
for the presidency but he did so because
he thought that it would be a good
opportunity to prop up other Progressive
candidates like Bernie Sanders on the
debate stage and then the DNC came out
once they caught wind of this and added
this qualification for appearing in the
debates that you had to in addition to
hitting the polling and fundraising
metrics also had to be quote running to
win to basically get rid of the
possibility of a sham candidate
appearing on the debate stage so it
really was a death now to microvel's
campaign it stopped all the momentum
that he had once the DNC came out with
this qualification in the same way Chris
Christie and ASA Hutchinson are coming
up with ways to be disqualified
themselves when not being in the debates
would also be death nails for their
campaigns so
for his part ASA Hutchinson he says that
pledges mean a lot to him and he seems
genuine when he says that he doesn't
want to sacrifice the Integrity of his
word by signing on to something that he
doesn't intend to follow through with
okay we can at least give him some
credit because he's operating on
principle here but this is the wrong
approach if you want to win right you
have to be more Cutthroat than that if
you're going to win especially when it
comes to Republican Party politics in
the year 2023 and it's just one more
reason why ASA Hutchinson and Chris
Christie probably don't have a serious
shot at winning this thing Florida
governor and Republican presidential
candidate Ron DeSantis is well behind
Donald Trump in the polls now something
like 30 points down and it's becoming
clear that if he's going to have any
path at winning this nomination he's
going to have to Market himself as the
better candidate when it comes to
particular segments of the Republican
base better than Donald Trump can so the
census has already shown that he's not
good at going after after Trump directly
he put off attacking Trump for the
longest time he's only recently started
to do it and he is not very good at it
he makes these half-hearted and
backhanded attacks against Donald Trump
and he often gets nervous while he does
so and you just can't land the blows
effectively well DeSantis is probably
not going to win that game and he
probably realizes this he just can't get
down into the mud with Donald Trump and
come out looking better than Trump does
because Trump has been doing this his
whole life and that's been his strategy
that's what won him over in the
Republican base but DeSantis might have
the smallest of chances if he's able to
Market himself to let's say the
religious right because Trump we suspect
is not a religious person himself
remember that he quoted two Corinthians
and he said that he couldn't name any
specific Bible passages when asked what
his favorites were because the question
was too personal on top of not knowing
anything about the religious texts he
also has lived a life that many would
consider to be sinful within the
Christian Community from his paying off
porn stars to his valuing of greed and
vanity and ego above everything else in
life to his countless lives there's a
lot of reasons to list why Trump is not
a holy person
and certainly doesn't seem to observe
religion and this lack of religiosity
was actually a major liability for Trump
back in the 2016 campaign and
evangelicals were holding out their
support of trump in favor of candidates
like Ted Cruz and Marco Rubio they only
came around to him by and large at the
very end DeSantis on the other hand
actually seems to know his stuff when it
comes to Christianity he can cite
Christian stories and passages he's
Roman Catholic which may not be the most
suitable for some Protestants and
specifically evangelicals in the country
but he at least can come across as a
Holier man than Donald Trump is if this
is the approach that he wants to take
and if this is what he thinks will give
him the best shot at winning the
election well DeSantis sat down for an
interview on the Christian Broadcasting
Network and he posed the question what
if I could have been there with Jesus's
disciples how cool would that have been
listen to Ronda Santos thinking about
this possibility if only he could have
been at the table with Jesus at the last
supper and then carried his message
forward to try to convince people of
Christianity let's take a look at the
clip could I have been there with
Jesus's disciples I mean you know these
are people who you know Peter's Just
Fishing one day and all of a sudden this
guy comes up to him catches all the fish
and says you know you're going to be
Fisher I want you to be a fisher of men
come with me and so these guys all went
out uh and they dedicated their life to
spreading the gospel and they all were
were killed for you know they tried to
kill John John ended up you know being
able to survive but I mean the intent
was to put him to death too and you know
to talk about what that was like
um you know talk about what their what
their impressions are you know what are
that I look back at that and would love
to have been been able to be there with
them so to his credit Ronda santis
actually sounds somewhat knowledgeable
about this he sounds like he knows the
scripture he's chatting up a storm about
Peter fishing and how many of the
disciples were killed but John was able
to survive of course the analysis comes
with delusions of grandeur right because
he thinks that he would fit in with
Peter and Matthew and John I guess it
would be Peter and Matthew and John and
Ron if he had it his way and he's acting
like he'd be brave enough to be one of
those disciples and put his life at risk
in order to carry out Jesus's message
but it's a hypothetical and he's talking
about how great it would be to live in
Antiquity and risk being put to death in
some horrible way but the broader point
is that maybe this can help him
ultimately win some votes with the
religious folks who think that oh yeah
Ron DeSantis could have been a disciple
of Jesus he's just that Holy of a guy
but now I want to get to Mary Hassan who
responded to Santos in hilarious fashion
after he saw this clip check this out
because meddy really hits the nail on
the head and articulates why this is
just absolutely hilarious much much
better than I can let's take a look at
medie's take now Aben put aside the
arrogance of a republican politician in
2023 suggesting he could be a disciple
of the Lord but just imagine for a
second if alongside Peter John James and
Co there had been a ROM a Ron who every
time Jesus helped the poor and used
loaves of bread and fish to feed the
hungry run was like you're too woke
Jesus you're too woke let them pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps
every time Jesus said I don't know we
should embrace refugees and migrants Rod
was like stop all the wokeness Jesus
send them to Martha's Vineyard the holy
land is where woke goes to die
I mean aiming the truth is that the
Jesus of the gospels and his disciples
were way too left-wing for Ronald
DeSantis so many Assan pointing out
there how Republican politics really
don't align whatsoever with the
teachings of Jesus and also making fun
of how Ron DeSantis manages to bring
every single issue back to wokism no
matter how far removed it may be
Maddie's guest in this interview goes on
to make another Salient point which is
that if there's an analogy to be drawn
here between the disciples and DeSantis
the analogy is to paint Donald Trump
actually as the Jesus figure believe it
or not and to portray DeSantis as Judas
the disciple who betrayed Jesus and
turned him into the authorities in
exchange for 30 pieces of silver and
that's because Trump did help the
scientists get elected the degree to
which Trump was useful is debated but
Trump did support DeSantis early on and
DeSantis had these fawning campaign ads
uh showing how he was raising his
children to be pro-maga now well because
DeSantis is seeking higher office he's
turned against Donald Trump and he wants
to be the leader himself so he's
effectively turned Trump in for that 30
pieces of silver just like Judas did to
Jesus now I don't actually think it's
logical to compare Trump to Jesus even
for a second right but I'm just saying
if there's an analogy to be drawn here
between DeSantis and the disciples
that's the one to make so that's Ron
DeSantis for you mixing in some religion
with his campaign we'll see if it does
him any good or if evangelicals will
continue to live with the cognitive
dissonance that they've been living with
for years and years supporting Donald
Trump despite the fact that he is a very
sinful and ungodly person
maybe Ron DeSantis has some shot if he
decides to go this route all right
that's going to do it for today's
episode of the David Pacman show it's
been an honor filling in for David today
Luke Beasley our correspondent and
occasional guest host is going to be
filling in for the rest of the week so
we're looking forward to that thank you
very much for watching and we'll see you
on the bonus show assuming you are a
member if you're not a member yet what
are you doing you got to make sure that
you get yourself a membership you do
that by going to joinpakman.com and once
you sign up for membership you'll be
able to see me on the other side on the
bonus show looking forward to it have a
great day everybody and we'll see you
next time
foreign
it's good to wear sunscreen year round
but it is really the time of year for
sunscreen right now you may have heard
FDA warnings about chemical sunscreens
which can cause skin irritation and
other issues that's why it's best to use
a mineral sunscreen like the one by
Ginger armor it is just as effective
much safer and you'll save 15 percent
with the code Pacman the link is down
below